let me go next to connie from kenosha
wisconsin hello
hi how are you i'm great how are you
i'm doing well feliz dia de los
veteranos
mucha gracias so
i am addicted to watching your show
and amongst everything else um
surrounding this mess that we're in um
but i have to wonder as far as
the transition that
has pretty much happened with every
other
um president-elect in the past
um why
is there no path around
um certain certain
blocks that they're encountering as far
as
the head of gsa um you know making
certain information available to joe
biden
i i'm really having a hard time
understanding
why it's just being
why this is being allowed so all of
these things are different
so so the important thing is to separate
out a lot of these different things so
trump hasn't conceded that's a formality
it doesn't relate to anything else it
doesn't change that he won't be
president anymore
on january 20th at noon then you've got
the gsa
question trump has not signed off and
authorized
gsa to sort of start involving
the biden elect camp in the transition
and that is an inconvenience but as joe
biden said earlier this week
it doesn't materially change anything
now joe biden is not currently the
president so he really can't do anything
about that
but the important thing to understand is
it won't change the fact that he will be
sworn in on january 20th
so it's important to sort of divide
these things up into which ones are just
sore loser-ish and which ones really
have an impact
the one that for me is the most
concerning is joe biden should be
receiving the presidential daily
briefing already and he's not as of
right now
that trump doesn't even read it well
sure you're right so at this but but so
to your point
we have a situation right now where
trump is miserable
and hiding out at the white house and
ignoring the pdb
biden's not getting it if i were
a terrorist enclave in some other
country i would be aware that the u.s is
very vulnerable right now because
they've got no one reading the pdb and
you're going to get a president coming
in on january 20th
who will not have been receiving it
unless something changes so i think it
actually puts
puts national security at risk well and
i think that it points out and
brings to light that donald trump truly
really does not have the country's best
interests at heart
never did and he absolutely does not
you're completely correct about that
right well kenosha's doing fine
everything's okay here
thank you still boarded up but yeah i'm
glad to hear that connie thank you for
calling in today
thank you very much love your show thank
you there's connie from kenosha what a
phone call
um i would even say maybe perfect phone
call i don't know